there's a political consultant who went
on MSNBC and said if you were supporting
Bernie Sanders over Elizabeth Warren
given everything that we know today you
are sexist I wish that this was a fake
headline it is not let's look at the
video of Emily Tisch Sussman's saying
this in her own words doing the thing
where she says some people are saying if
you support Bernie over Warren it's
sexist and I think there might be
something to it
take a look there's there's a ceiling
there is nowhere to go but there is no
up to go and all of those who I actually
heard overheard someone saying that I
thought was an interesting point that
basically at this point if you are still
supporting Sanders as opposed to Warren
it's kind of showing your sexism because
she has more detailed plans and her
plans have evolved I thought it was an
interesting point and I think there may
be something to it yeah I agree with all
that what there are about there's at
least three layers through which we need
to analyze this three lenses through
which we need to try to understand this
first of all it's just the sheer
stupidity of this comment if you have
two candidates and one is male and
another is female if supporting the male
is a sign of sexism against the female
candidate then by extrapolation from
that if you have a Jewish candidate and
a Christian candidate and you support
the Christian candidate Elizabeth Warren
in this case that must be anti-semitism
against the Jewish candidate Bernie
Sanders right no I would be an idiot if
I tried to make that argument I would
immediately lose all credibility to put
forth any kind of political analysis
which is why I'm not going to make such
a stupid argument and that's equally
dumb as what Emily tissue Sherman
Sussman says here that's the argument
that's being made and I hesitate to even
use the term argument because it's not
really an argument it's just nonsense so
that's problem number one the argument
is idiotic secondly we have here the
growing problem that I've been telling
you about last week I did a segment
where I said the crits
geeks from left to left the critiques
among Democratic primary voters of other
Democratic candidates are starting to
get to be the level of toxicity that is
going to hurt the eventual nominee and
help Donald Trump in 2020 ok these are
the types of more vicious and inaccurate
attacks that are going to self-destruct
and lead to the re-election of Donald
Trump and there are all sorts of reasons
why someone might support Bernie Sanders
over Elizabeth Warren and there are
reasons people are supporting Elizabeth
Warren over Bernie Sanders none of which
have to do with religion or gender
Bernie for example has been clear that
Medicare for all is the path forward for
health care now you can agree or
disagree with that that's his position
Elizabeth Warren has been more wishy
washy now you might agree with Warren
there are reasonable people who can say
you know I don't want to put all my eggs
in the medicare-for-all basket and so I
like Elizabeth Warren's more open-minded
approach or you could say I don't see
Elizabeth Warren as open-minded I see
her merely as wishy-washy and then
willing to take a position I'm going
with Bernie on this issue none of that
has to do with religion none of that has
to do with gender Warren voted for a
bigger Pentagon budget
Bernie voted against it that might be a
reason to vote for Bernie has nothing to
do with sexism obviously Bernie won't
take corporate PAC money in the general
and Elizabeth Warren will there's a big
argument to be had about that on the one
hand do you want someone who is
potentially going to be at a
disadvantage merely because they're
saying I won't take PAC money and my
opponent will and that hurts me or you
could say I love that Bernie is not
going to compromise principles and he is
not going to take corporate PAC money in
the general whatever right I'm just
telling you what the arguments are to
say that supporting the male candidate
because as Emily Tish Susman said
Warren's plans are more detailed
supposedly is absurd and pathetic it's
it actually is it's so sad that this is
what things have come to these are
ridiculous attacks that are baseless at
their core but they're destructive to
the movement there are serious critiques
and disagreements anyone can have with
Bernie or with Warren but this is a
surd childish and counterproductive now
the other thing layer three as we might
call it is that this particular
consultant or pundit or whatever Emily
Tish Sussman she is part of the
Democratic establishment that has shown
that they don't like Bernie she's the
former vice president of campaigns for
the Center for American Progress an
establishment Democratic outfit her
father Donald Sussman was one of the top
Hillary donors in 2016
donating more than 22 million dollars to
Hillary so I think you probably
understand what's going on here this is
truly terrible stuff you hate to see it
if what you care about is removing
Donald Trump in 2020 and unfortunately
more and more Democrats are doing it I'm
not saying everybody's the same not
every candidate has this going on to the
same degree but we've seen enclaves of
toxic Bernie supporters we've seen toxic
enclaves of Bernie detractors we've seen
Biden supporters who were doing right
wing talking points about socialism and
communism about Bernie and Warren we've
seen anti Biden people that are going
well beyond what the evidence tells us
should be the case and against Biden
into what our smears we've seen Warren
detractors we've seen the cult of
personality around Tulsi supporter on
Tulsi Gabbard with some of her
supporters yang supporters I've been
some of them have been going over the
line this is getting bad this is exactly
how we lose and I hope I mean what else
can I say
I hope that everybody realizes this and
abandons this strategy